target field downtown minneapolis
minnesota the site for game three of
this series
they have split the first two and the
indians will turn to carlos carrasco
they've got to face kenta maeda the
former dodger right-hander and hopefully
they can find some early offense because
that has been the key to their success
so far scoring first when they score
first they are five and all when they
don't
kenta maeda making his first target
field
appearance off to a
1-0 start after a very well-pitched game
down in chicago last week hernandez got
a couple of hits last night on the
ground
gathered in by
one pitch one out
here's jose ramirez
and now to polanco
two down a couple of quick ground ball
outs that'll bring up lindor with the
bases empty
and off the plate ball four two out walk
keeps the inning alive for carlos
santana
swinging a fly ball center field deep
and playable buxton on the grass and
right center he'll call he will catch
above his red twins cap and that's out
number three second start of the
campaign for carlos carrasco's we go to
the bottom of the first in a scoreless
game the right-hander facing max kepler
the right fielder now the payoff swing
and a miss wicked changeup and the
bottom fell out of it and carrasco
strikes out kepler for out number one
two down for nelly cruz the dh and he's
batting 370 with four career homers
against carrasco
rolls over and lindor to his left about
a step or two to throw him out the twins
go one two three lyon banning 200 the
pits to him and here comes and that
strike three call knee high 92 leone
thought it was maybe a tad low and now
the rookie daniel johnson and the 1-2
pitch he got him strike three no
fastballs to end that at bat off speed
off speed off speed and johnson's out
number two
and now hernandez
2-2 strike three call the fastball 93
maeda strikes out the side
miguel 1 for 17 to start the year with
eight strikeouts
driven to the gap and left center field
that ball is a bullet and gone
into the bullpen
and the twins
take the first lead
[Music]
there are not too many hitters
anywhere in the world that can hit a
ball
at that height above the ground
and have it carry out uh up 400 feet
away that ball as dixon this is scalding
absolutely tattooed
that powerful sway that's i think that's
his
struck him out on something down and
away here's strikeout number four for
miata
rosario hits this ball well to left
field left fielder tracking johnson
he'll look up and go and eddie rosario
home run into the flower beds in left
field twinsley two to nothing now danny
as we said for his first at-bat he has
more games more hits more home runs more
rbis off cleveland pitching than any
other one team adding to that
that's his 21st career home run
and his 100th career hits off cleveland
pitching here's luisa rise bounce to
second his first time up
arise shooting these young guys came up
zimmer with a nice catch going to the
backhand
slide and the inning is over
there's two hits on the year they both
been extra bases
to the left field corner it's deep and
gone he's got another one
and that left the ballpark as quickly as
the first one
you know when he hits him roy i'm glad i
don't have a home run call because i
don't think i'd be able to fit the words
in you wouldn't be able to get them all
in but if you want to get it in by the
time it hits the seats you wouldn't be
able to do it
so i said the first one was tattooed i
guess scalded i'm going to run out of
adjectives as well
this is a beautiful swing on a breaking
ball that hung right kind of inside
middle
there's trevor
in the seventh
polanco backhands and fires across and
so with the tag a good play by miguel
ceneaux
and a great throw by polanco from the
hole
i think i mentioned last night that
jorge palaco has as good an armed from
the funny position body positions as
anybody look at this throw across the
body in the air
to snow
look how quickly he gets rid of the ball
across his body all the way over in the
air so snow can throw the tag on trevor
may say man that that could have been
two guys on there that's a heck of a
play
rogers protected a three-run lead last
night and that's what he's asked to do
tonight faisal and dorr
he's played a lot of third base stays
with that just goes down to the knees to
make sure that he can get down to the
ball and keep it above the ground
one and two
to santana
two down
front meal reyes another 2-2 got him
rogers gets the job done again the twins
pitching has held the indians to three
runs scored in the first three games of
this series